you look you look a little different
tonight I'm trying to figure out what it
is you're you're quite well quaffed
oh no I mean that you I man go right
down the barrel yeah camera three
they'll take their time but they'll do
it look it's not great but I'm 43 that's
okay 43 you know what happened my wife
insisted I watched this show with her
Queer Eye for the straight guy this is
the new version the new version that's
on that show sure you guys there you
know what a reboot people I will say
this I've heard people raving about it
yeah I thought oh it's a reboot how good
could it be I'll be on that's my thought
those first guys they hit it just right
and then sadly they were all lost in an
accident but yeah a bad maritime acts
yeah tried to go to ice well I'm
suspicious when they reboot and then
I've been hearing from everyone then
they're terrific well look I didn't want
to watch it because there's no dragons
or swords or any of that stuff well they
find this adorable gentleman down in the
south and he's older and he's got some
redness and they start putting on like a
redness I'm just ready on the face yeah
I'm not gonna say whether it was rosacea
or whatever it was
suffice to say like the color this
microphone and they put on this green
top stick and boy that redness started
going away mm-hmm and then he had some
puffy eyes they put on this ice mask on
him and then that puffiness went away
and then he had a beard not unlike mine
and it was very dry and they added a
beard oil to it and educators love beard
oil
there's beard oil and it made his beard
luxurious and moist looking mm-hmm so I
ordered all those products right I
bought every single one of them and as
they were arriving I didn't really want
my wife to see but she started noticing
I had all these products and I started
using him and boy it's had the same
reaction for me yeah yeah you do look
very good in my beard looks moist and I
know I might
you know like a like a cake yeah I got
ya I'm like a dense cut too sure never
I've never walk up to a man and say your
beard looks nice and moist
you wouldn't okay I don't think I would
do that I would be very flattered if you
said that yeah what you would say it
like moist beard bro yeah super moist
being a beard boy no I would not do that
you